this program is brought to you by Emory
University
well may 14th 2010 I'll never forget
that date I just had an anniversary and
it was an unusual feeling because I sort
of felt I was wearing this bulletproof
jacket for health
I was always considered to be in great
condition and my wife came home one
afternoon and I was laying on the floor
and couldn't move and she normally
wouldn't have come in for very long but
she came in heard the dog that you know
making some weird noises very unusual
for her and wanted to come into the room
and saw me laying on the floor my wife
was there to rescue me and and I praise
the Lord for the fact that it wasn't
very long after I had the stroke that we
were in the ambulance and headed to
Emory
athlete I felt like I was here with
Vince Lombardi Joe Gibbs some of the top
coaches that ever been ever you know
even high school college even on the
professional level my coach here was
like a Vince Lombardi that just
challenged me said that okay Joe what
are some of the things that you want to
accomplish in here what are some of the
goals that you have
you know what it did is it really just
built a tremendous amount of confidence
as I went through this process and had a
great you know counselor who worked
directly with me we actually pushed me
and most people that know me know that I
don't need a whole lot of pushing
because being an ex-athlete that's just
something that's naturally mean I always
want to win and I felt like going
through this program I wasn't going to
let the stroke and the heart attack I'd
beaten confidence not something that can
go to a department store like a Walmart
or Kmart or Sears and purchase it
because there's not it's not on sale
it's one of the things that you actually
have for yourself that conference has to
be built in based on all the things that
you work on as you go through any kind
of program
it's almost like going back to school
and being in elementary where I want to
write I was an artist so I wanted to be
able to write again and write
effectively where people could
understand what I what it was that I was
putting on the paper and we started out
with a J the first J what's horrible and
you know through the course of time I
was able to make a jade that look
legible and being able to satisfy myself
you know coach wants you to satisfy what
a coach wants out of you but then you
have to have that inner drive to say
okay now I've done something to make him
feel good or her feel good how do I make
myself feel good and so I began to do
the J and the J look good and I went on
with the O and I did the Jo E
but then I had over
that I want to accomplish inside the
program and that was being able to shoot
baskets having a bad left hand you know
our impaired left hand I hate to say bad
cuz I want to put that in the atmosphere
but I couldn't hold a basketball well
when I finished I was able to not only
hold the basketball I was able to shoot
and I made a basket and it's and then
also I went from there because I'm on
the skies and drive hard was to pick up
a golf club well the first time I picked
up the golf club it did not work with me
it fell right back down so I had to pick
it up two or three different times
before I was able to handle it and then
we put it which was interesting to say
the least
but I but I was able to accomplish those
things but then I didn't stop here what
they did is they instilled some
confidence in me that I just thought
what if I take this home and start
putting into real life you know things
that I need to do around the house and
now I'm doing gosh about 10 or 15 things
that I never thought I'd have the
opportunity to do and I am so I'm just
excited well one I'm able to get on the
riding lawnmower and and not only
directly but I can turn with my left and
my right and that was a huge accountant
because I said and washed my lawnmower
all the time I used to have other people
come in and cut my lawn now I do myself
driving and I was told I wouldn't be
able to drive for a while cuz it would
probably impair someone else in the
event that I had a stroke so I'm very
tentative when I get in a vehicle now
but my wife stays with me and that
that's so important because I start out
with one block in the neighborhood and I
went to two blocks I still would not get
on an interstate because I just think
that I really feel like I'm 100%
rehabilitated so I do not want to you
know and you know affect someone else's
life someone else's loved one
but I'll tell you one thing is that I
think is extremely important when I
first started the program I had
breathing issues I think it was like I
was anxious you know there was there was
a drive here from an athletic standpoint
that I thought I could do all these
things and I mean this is just a little
tiny setback well wasn't a tiny setback
was pretty huge and I think when I
started things I was I found myself
grasping for gasping for air and and
over the course of time when I took the
I care program they sort of steadied me
from not being so anxious but to be more
relaxed and my breathing became a lot
easier which allowed me to take on even
more challenges and I'm even today I'm
still taking on more and more challenges
but I also have been reminded that you
know Joe you did just a year ago yet to
do what most people considered to be
devastating you know impairment so don't
be the old Joe do everything in
moderation take your time have a slower
evolvement back to yourself and I would
say that to anyone who has gone through
what I had gone through and just take
your time doomed don't be in a hurry
it's all going to come back because I
did I yeah I just yesterday I had a full
day of activities but they're not paid
for it last night because I was
extremely tired and wasn't sure that I
was going to be able to get up properly
but I you know the Lord opened my eyes
and said Joe we're not done with you and
I would say that to all the other folks
who are in my situation the Lord is
going to decide what he's ready for you
and do as much as you can but do it in
moderation
I've had a year a little over a year now
but I just celebrated my anniversary
three days ago and and then still feel
like that I'm going to beat this still
have a little bit of impairment in my
hand but if you see both hands or they
look normal
so I'm very fortunate and I'm excited
about what I am doing right now by being
a testimony to some of the folks who
might come behind me who might be in a
position to take the same program and
also benefit
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University